ahora consideremos expresiones con más
de una variable supongamos que tenemos
la expresión
más
b b y nos preguntan cuánto vale la
expresión cuando a es igual a 5 y b es
igual a 7 cuánto es entonces a mars b en
este caso sustituimos el valor de a
igual a 5 más ve que vale 7 57 esto es
igual a 57 es igual a 12 hagamos otra
expresión supongamos que tenemos 10
x 10 x x menos
- 3 - 3 x
una de asur -3% y calculemos cuánto vale
esta expresión cuando x es igual a menos
y que es igual a 5 evaluemos la tenemos
que 10 por x cuando x es igual a menos 1
esto va a ser entonces 10 x menos 110 x
menos 1 - 3 x 5 menos 3 porque cuando
llegue es igual a 5 menos 3 por 5 y
ahora esto cuánto nos da 10 x menos 110
x menos 1 es menos 10 menos 3 por 5 por
orden de precedencia hay que hacer la
multiplicación primero así es que esto
es 3 por 5 15 menos 15 tenemos que es
menos 10 menos 15 y esto es igual a
menos menos 25 y ahora puedes hacer los
ejercicios que siguen para practicar
esto un poco más